[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
so
only took about five and a half hours
let me give you the tour
i'm gonna call for today go ice my arm
and i gotta go get a bigger saw to cut
down some of those bigger trees
[Music]
back to work
we're gonna come back
[Music]
and thank you for letting me
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
you ready
tommy i think you crashed
um
[Music]
you having a good time jacob
[Music]
well we got a lot done but we need to
call it for today and i need to get
jacob home and in the bath
yeah that's right we never drink
chainsaw gas and we never drink oil
little hot dog break hits the spot
[Music]
oh well cutting down trees is the easy
part now i have to limb all these trees
chop them up and stack them
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you guys have fun yeah
look how dirty i am then
you guys are filthy i think we all need
baths let's go home
yeah i've been working on removing these
stumps by hand and it's just taking
forever it's taking two to four hours
per stomp and on the big ones it can
take me all day it's just physically
demanding so uh i rented a little piece
of equipment that might help it go a
little bit faster
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
this thing is so much fun i wonder what
my wife would say if i bought one no no
no
no
well it took me six hours but we got all
the stumps removed now we just need to
grade this thing
all right things are looking pretty good
check it out
[Music]
it's a saturday we got the whole family
here
and now i gotta lay some fabric down
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this fabric helps you keep the gravel
from getting pounded down into the mud
however you have to install it correctly
and you see here that it got all bunched
up
and it got shoved down in the ruts and
so it's not going to do its job if the
fabric isn't working or you don't have
fabric you use big rocks and then you
put your crush and run on top so we're
probably going to be doing that to help
us get out of this muddy bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude
there we go we got the road done
whoo and it looks awesome
you guys ready to go down to the
property
[Music]
you are all weirdos
well guys i'm not sure what happened to
the summer but here we are the day
before thanksgiving and we got the whole
family here back at the property
was out running some errands yesterday
and i ended up buying a motorcycle on a
splurge
oh we get so injured
[Applause]
this is your break
there goes big mama on her boss hog
why don't you guys make a nice big fire
pit right there
[Applause]
it's only a high of 40 degrees which
means no insects and you don't need to
refrigerate anything
dinner tonight
gonna have some chicken legs
and we got some hot dogs
you need to forget one thing on every
campout this camp out it was ketchup
i assume everybody wants marshmallows in
their hot chocolate
that is so good thank you eddie thank
you dad
zach fowler with the youtube channel
fowler's makery and mischief he gave us
a bunch of these awesome slingshots the
guy is like a slingshot guru we're gonna
shoot at little targets here
we'll spread it out
becca's got a work email or something
she's got to deal with so we're going to
heat up the trailer and let her do her
thing in here
i bet there is i'm going to eat cookie
tonight boys are heading off into the
woods with their slingshots to go hunt
turkeys for thanksgiving
you guys going to get one for
thanksgiving
all right go get them
[Music]
got some fig marmalade some smoked gouda
thank you i love this so much
we have a blueberry pie for dessert
we're gonna go warm this up over the
fire
tommy is that chicken looking good
yeah look at that
some cinnamon butter in that squash
i like yours i like your bench
an animal from its vibration
you like the squash there jake
yeah all right we're going to put some
pie on here warm that up
some blueberry pie
it's a really good bingo and i'm pumping
my favorite
i feel bad for you i'm guessing
[Applause]
[Music]
we're supposed to get to 21 degrees
tonight and i'm really trying to keep
becca warm make sure she has a good
experience so i'm breaking out the big
gun i've got a negative 25 bag from
feathered friends and we've got the
indoor propane heater and if that
doesn't work i've also got a generator
and electric blanket becca is not
getting cold tonight it's time for bed
see you guys in the morning
hi good morning you sleep well
yeah you're warm yes this bag is amazing
[Applause]
by the time everyone gets out their
seats will be nice and warm well guys
today's thanksgiving and i've got a lot
to be thankful for but it's also a busy
day i'm gonna make a full thanksgiving
meal over the fire over there and we're
gonna start working on our next project
we're gonna build an obstacle course or
a homestead play set i want something to
entertain the kids so that when i'm down
here working on projects i can bring the
family and they'll be entertained and
have fun
oh eggnog is good for breakfast this
morning we're making eggnog french toast
with a brioche loaf in case you don't
know what brioche is it's a sweet
breakfast bread
here you go mama oh that looks so good
thank you so much is that yummy
his yummy is really yummy
i think this is where i need to build a
little playset obstacle course well guys
i think the first thing we need to do is
build a ladder
three
when i look up
that's why women live longer than men
this is a buoy we use for pulling
anchors
we're gonna test it out with the
youngest one
[Music]
well now the kids are entertained do you
think i should make dinner sounds great
if you're up for it
thank you
so you've kind of figured like
do
there you go mashed potatoes
there's our turkey looking good fresh
rolls got some sweet potatoes and
veggies
warmed up gravy homemade cranberry sauce
i made yesterday mashed potatoes
stuffing and we got marshmallow butter
yams it looks so good thank you so much
that is good
who wants turkey legs
you got a roll in one hand a turkey leg
in the other double fist in thanksgiving
that looks pretty darn
and things there's yummy good
there's some blueberry pie are you
having a good thanksgiving yeah it's a
great thanksgiving i'm thankful for
daddy
thankful for mommy
well after all the cooking i did
yesterday daddy gonna phone it in got a
lot of work to do don't want to spend
all day cooking
some hot apple cider oh thank you
wow
it's really good
i found an rv surplus cargo and i
figured that'd be a good feature for our
playset
oh looks like we got some company our
good friends the petersons are here
joining us hey guys glad you made it
give it a try go see what you do
i found these tractor tires in this
culvert at an illegal dumping site that
was being cleaned up and i think the
boys are gonna enjoy playing with that
did it work it works
sorry
hi kids
go go
[Music]
[Music]
i think i better pause this and go get
some dinner made you ladies hungry
i get like little
um
all right guys we're ready let's go grab
some plates and utensils here we're
gonna we got a lot of food
all right we have you need to sit down
hey tommy are you roasting rice krispie
treats yes
well it's been fun but our friends are
heading home so we're saying goodbye
bye-bye
[Music]
well it's a cold saturday morning and i
think dad needs to get up get the fire
started get the heater on and uh
get things going
well i'll tell you what this little
homestead campsite and playground turned
out really well but i've got a lot of
projects i want to do yet but if you
guys want to see more of that make sure
to click subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning so thanks for
watching guys
nailed it
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]